The first unit of CS212 uses poker as a vehicle to
teach about the design of computer programs. If you
don’t know the rules of poker yet, don’t worry, that’s
exactly what this video is for. Now of all you know
about poker is what you’ve seen on TV or in a
casino, you may think it’s pretty complicated. There
is that intimidating green table and it’s surrounded
by some very serious looking people and these
people often have very silly hats or ridiculous
sunglasses and they are saying things like, raise, or
all-in. Now if you ever want to actually play poker,
you are going to have to learn what all this means.
There is betting, there is folding, there is calling,
there is raising, and it can get pretty complicated.
There is a lot of strategy involved. But for the
purposes of this unit, we only need to know the most
basic aspect of poker and this aspect is common to
every single variation of poker and that’s how hands
are arranged because at the end of the day, all of
these different versions of poker have to do with
making the best five card hand that you can. Now
these different hands each have different names and
there are nine of them. So let’s talk about what each
of these names mean and since this class uses
python, I’ll start my numbering at zero.
The best hand and this one that you almost never
see in poker is the straight flush and here we have a
straight flush. The suit here is hearts, so you can
see every single card is a heart and they are all in
sequential order, nine, ten, jack, queen, king. If you
ever go into a poker form online, you would see
these cards were in as 9H, TH, JH, QH, KH and
that’s the system we’re going to use here.
The next best hand is four of a kind and here we
have a four of a kind with four aces and a six. The
six is usually irrelevant to this hand but we’ll talk a
little bit about how to break ties in class. Next best is
the full house and a full house is just three cards of
one rank, so here we have three tens and two of
another, so two, twos. This hand is a full house so
we would call it tens full of twos. Next is the flush
and a flush is five cards of the same suit and here
the ranks don’t matter. You can see we have a
three, six, jack, queen and king but they’re all of the
suit spade. Next we have the street and a street is
just five cards in sequential order, five, six, seven,
eight, nine and here the suit doesn’t matter at all.
We have a spade, diamond, club, diamond and
another spade. Our next hand is the three of a kind
and three of a kind is just three cards of the same
rank, so these three fours are what’s relevant. The
queen and again in some special circumstances
where we’re playing with multiple decks, they may
be used to break a tie and again we’ll talk about that
in class. Next we have two pair, for example, a pair
of jacks and a pair of nines would be two pair. The
second worst hand is a pair and a pair is just two
cards of the same rank, here we have two threes.
The eight, five, two don’t do much to help our hand
here. Finally, we have nothing. So we could also call
that high card because when two people who have
nothing show down their hands, the one with the
highest card wins.
Here we have king high and this is really quite a bad
hand. If you are ever in a casino, I wouldn’t go
playing this and expecting win. And that’s it; those
are our nine hands, straight flush, four of a kind, full
house, flush, straight, three of a kind, two pair, pair
and nothing. Noticeably design them all in number,
zero through eight. This is one of the numbers we’ll
be using in our poker program to compare hands. It
turns out, we’ll need a few other numbers to
distinguish between for example two full houses, six
for six is inadequate, we’ll need to add some other
numbers in there but we’ll explain that in class and
for now you should understand the rules of poker
well enough to follow on.